[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les forces
existe-t-elle vraiment une force est une
action qui va changer le mouvement d'un
objet en temps normal un objet a
tendance à conserver son mouvement et
notamment sa direction et sa vitesse
mais parfois il arrive qu'ils changent
de direction ou de vitesse quelque chose
s'est produit à modifier son mouvement
et on dit qu'il a subi une force
à première vue on peut classifier toutes
les forces de l'univers en trois
catégories
tout d'abord on peut penser à la force
qui nous plaque en arrière quand une
voiture accélère ou à la force
centrifuge qui nous repousse quand la
voiture tourne on appelle ce genre de
force des forces d'entraînement elles
apparaissent le plus souvent à
l'intérieur d'un véhicule quand il
accélère ou qu'il tourne ensuite on peut
penser aux forces qui agissent à
distance on en distingue deux
principales la gravité qui attire les
objets massifs et la force
électromagnétique qui attire ou repousse
les charges et les aimants enfin la
troisième catégorie regroupe toutes les
forces de contact il s'agit des forces
de pression de traction de torsion et de
déformation ou encore des forces de
frottement toutes ses forces ont la
particularité de s'exercer localement au
travers d'un contact physique entre deux
objets
à elles seules ces trois catégories
permettent de classifier toutes les
forces de l'univers mais ses forces
existe-t-elle vraiment sont elles des
lois fondamentales ou alors sont elles
plutôt la conséquence d'autres
phénomènes
pour répondre à cette question nous
allons nous pencher sur chacune des
trois catégories
tout d'abord commençons par les force
d'entraînement comme exemple on peut
imaginer un passager à l'intérieur d'une
voiture qui démarre quand la voiture se
met en mouvement une force
d'entraînement apparaît et repousse le
passager dans son siège de son point de
vue quand la voiture accélère une force
apparaît et entraîne tous les objets
vers l'arrière à première vue pour le
passager cette force existe elle lui est
nécessaire pour pouvoir comprendre le
mouvement des objets qui sont entraînés
vers l'arrière mais s'il décide de
regarder par la fenêtre
le passager réalise qu'il n'est pas le
seul à subir cette force quand la
voiture démarre tous les objets de
l'univers semble reculer en même temps
comme si cette même force s'appliquer
partout quand on y réfléchit
cette situation est absurde comment la
voiture pourrait-elle influencé tout
l'univers de façon instantanée
on aurait plutôt envie de dire qu'une
étoile
à l'autre bout du cosmos ne peut pas
être influencée par le démarrage d'une
voiture et encore moins de façon
instantanée pour résoudre ce paradoxe
il suffit en fait de changer de point de
vue
au lieu de dire que tous les objets
accélère vers l'arrière excepté la
voiture il suffit de regarder la
situation depuis l'extérieur et de dire
que c'est la voiture qui subit une force
vers l'avant alors que le reste de
l'univers n'est pas affectée le passager
a l'impression qu'il existe une force
parce qu il se repère par rapport à la
voiture
alors que c'est justement elle qui est
en train de subir une force la force de
frottement des roues contre le sol cette
façon de raisonner ne s'applique pas
uniquement dans une voiture et se
généralise à toutes les forces
d'entraînement toutes ces forces ont la
particularité de s'appliquer en même
temps à tous les objets de l'univers et
on en déduit qu'il ne peut pas s'agir de
vraie force physique que ce sont des
illusions des forces fictive qui
apparaissent car on se repère par
rapport à un objet qui lui même subi une
force
cela dit quand on pousse le raisonnement
on réalise qu'il existe d'autres forces
qui semble également agir partout dans
l'univers ce sont les forces de la
deuxième catégorie les actions à
distance pour commencer
penchons nous sur le cas de la gravité
quand on lâche une pomme la pomme est
accélérée vers le sol et on dit qu'elle
subit une force vers le bas c'est
l'attraction de la terre tant que la
pomme n'a pas touché le sol elle semble
constamment attiré par la terre à
distance mais la pomme n'est pas la
seule
tous les objets de l'univers semble
également attirés par la terre comme si
celle-ci imprimait une même force une
gravitation universelle à tous les corps
qui existe
au même titre que l'exemple précédent on
peut se demander s'il est bien
raisonnable de penser que la terre
puisse influencer tout l'univers
après tout comme pour la voiture il
serait plus simple de dire que l'univers
n'est pas influencée par la terre que ce
ne sont pas les objets qui tombent tous
vers le bas mais simplement le sol qui
accélère vers le haut comme dans la
voiture la force de gravité ne serait
qu'une force d'entraînement elle
apparaît car on regarde le mouvement des
objets par rapport au sol alors que
c'est précisément le sol qui est en
train d'accélérer
a priori cette vision est plus élégante
au lieu d'inventer une nouvelle force
mystérieuse la gravité il suffit de dire
que c'est le sol qui monte
on observe que les objets se rapproche
du sol pas parce qu'ils tombent mais
parce que la surface accélère vers le
haut
cela dit il est facile de percevoir que
cette explication à elle seule ne
fonctionne pas en effet si c'est
réellement le sol qui accélère vers le
haut comment expliquer que la terre ne
grossit pas au cours du temps
si c'était le cas on devrait observer
que la planète s'élargit et elle
finirait par se disloquer
pourtant la terre n'a pas changé de
taille depuis des milliards d'années et
les objets continuent de tomber à sa
surface
la réponse à ce problème et très subtil
et constitue l'une des découvertes les
plus bouleversantes de la physique
moderne
la terre est bel et bien en train de
gonfler sa surface accélère constamment
vers l'extérieur car elle est poussée
par la pression et la chaleur des
matériaux qui la composent
mais si la planète ne grossit pas c'est
parce que l'espace tout autour d'elle le
tissu dans lequel lé contenu est
également en train de se comprimer dans
l'autre sens on appelle ce phénomène la
courbure de l'espace-temps la terre
n'influence pas directement les objets
dans l'univers elle ne leur imprime pas
une force à distance la planète ne fait
que gonfler mais comme elle est très
massives la terre comprime le tissu de
l'univers dans l'autre sens
de cette façon la planète gonfle dans un
espace qui se compriment et les deux
effets se compense parfaitement cette
façon de comprendre l'univers est ce
qu'on appelle la relativité générale on
introduit le fait que l'espace temps
puisse se courber pour pouvoir supprimer
la notion de gravité tout comme la force
d'entraînement dans la voiture la
gravité est une illusion
on observe que la pomme tombe par
rapport à la surface de la terre
alors que c'est en réalité la surface
qui est en train de subir une force vers
le haut la pression de la planète qui
l'empêchent de s'effondrer sur elle-même
on a désormais compris que la gravité
n'est autre qu'une force d'entraînement
fictive et il ne nous reste que deux
catégories les interactions à distance
dont la force électromagnétique et les
forces de contact mais lorsqu'on y
réfléchit
les forces de contacts ne sont que des
approximations à grande échelle
en réalité la matière qui compose les
objets et formé d'atomes
quand on observe une force de contact à
grande échelle
il s'agit à la base d'une interaction
entre les atomes de chacun des deux
objets quand on pousse un objet par
exemple la force de contact n'existe pas
vraiment elle est la synthèse à grande
échelle de toutes les forces
électromagnétiques qui font se repousser
les électrons et donc les atomes de
notre main et de l'objet en fin de
compte les forces de contacts ne sont
rien d'autre que la manifestation à
grande échelle de la force
électromagnétique ainsi mis à part les
force d'entraînement qui sont des
illusions
les seules vraies forces de l'univers
semble d'être les interactions
fondamentales qui se produisent à
l'échelle des particules ans dans notre
univers
elles sont au nombre de trois
l'interaction électromagnétique qui
explique pourquoi les électrons se
repoussent et qui est donc à la base de
toutes les forces de contact
l'interaction forte qui permet
d'expliquer la cohésion des protons et
les neutrons au sein des atomes et
l'interaction faible dont découlent les
phénomènes de radioactivité à elles
seules ces trois interactions
fondamentales décrivent les forces que
subissent toutes les particules et donc
tous les objets de l'univers
mais pourtant un problème subsiste bien
que l'on ait réussi à identifier ces
trois forces fondamentales de l'univers
elle semble toujours agir à distance
quand on approche deux électrons par
exemple il se repoussent à distance
comme si les électrons pouvait se
communiquer une information sans entrer
en contact à nouveau cette situation par
est absurde
comment les deux électrons qui sont
séparés par une certaine distance
pourrait-il interagir instantanément en
réalité tout se passe comme si les
électrons étaient deux personnes en
train de s'échanger une balle lorsqu un
électron lance la balle vers l'autre
l'asymétrie de la situation force
l'électron a reculé dans le sens opposé
pour comprendre si on considère que
l'électron est la balle ne constitue
qu'un seul objet est que cet objet n'a
aucune raison de se déplacer au cours du
temps quand la balle part vers la droite
l'électron est forcé de partir vers la
gauche pour compenser en lançant la
balle dans une direction
l'électron a acquis un mouvement dans la
direction opposée
et c'est précisément ce qu'on interprète
comme une force
cette façon de comprendre les
interactions fondamentales provient de
ce qu'on appelle la théorie quantique
des champs avec la relativité générale
il s'agit des deux piliers fondateurs à
la base de toute la physique moderne
la théorie quantique des champs nous
explique que les particules sont
constamment en train de s'échanger des
intermédiaires qu'on appelle des
particules virtuelles
il s'agit des photons pour la force
électromagnétique des gluons pour
l'interaction forte et des particules z
et w pour l'interaction faible par
symétrie
tous ces échanges de particules
virtuelles permettent de modifier
progressivement le mouvement des objets
et c'est cet effet de recul lorsqu'une
particules émet ou absorbent une
particule virtuel que l'on interprète à
notre échelle comme une force
il serait donc faux de dire que les
forces n'existe pas en fin de compte à
l'intérieur d'une voiture quand elle
accélère les objets sont bien décrits
par une force d'entraînement mais cette
force d'entraînement n'est qu'un outil
de calcul une description mathématiques
qui fonctionne dans le référentiel de la
voiture les force d'entraînement dont
font partie la force centrifuge la force
de coriolis et même la force de gravité
ne sont après tout que des illusions qui
disparaissent quand on adopte un point
de vue approprié
cela dit même en mettant de côté les
forces d'entraînement et semble toujours
existé une multitude de force qu'on
appelle les forces de contact force de
pression de tensions ou encore de
frottement toutes ses forces permettent
de décrire l'interaction entre les corps
à notre échelle mais lorsqu'on plonge
dans la matière
on réalise que s'efforce de contacts ne
sont que des modélisations à grande
échelle
en réalité elles émergent de simplement
trois forces fondamentales qui explique
à elle seule l'évolution de toutes les
particules
cela dit ces trois forces de base ne
sont elles même pas vraiment
fondamentale car elle découle en fin de
compte d'un principe beaucoup plus
simple d'une notion plus pur naturel
inhérentes à la géométrie et à la
structure de l'univers lui-même à
laquelle on réfère souvent en parlant d'
action réaction
c'est la notion de symétrie
[Musique]